[Music]
hi
i'm olga kurelenko and this is my
glamour unfiltered
[Music]
well it was you know i had to put it
away in my mind and
you know somehow forget about it and
pretend
it didn't happen to myself really so
that i wouldn't even be
you know wouldn't be tempted but i
usually i'm usually quite good at
secrets and
i you know if i i don't talk so
um yeah i kept it away from my mother
uh she she only found out three days ago
finally everyone everyone found out so
it's over
i wish i could say hundred percent i i
did it all by myself but taking account
the task master's skills are
quite complex and incredible and there's
nothing she can't do really because she
mimics the opponent
um i had to be yeah i had to be dubbed
um and not and usually in films
you know an actor has one stunt double
um
that you know that look like them
somehow and
uh in this case in this movie i had
i had like three or four stunt doubles
the skills are so complicated they
couldn't even find one
one stunt person who could
encompass all those skills there's just
no people like that apparently so
every person there was a different
person who was specialized in something
and depending on the moves the
taskmaster had to do they would put that
person in the suit
i think it's very important all the
discussions that have been going on
and you know nowadays with the
woman empowerment women empowerment it's
it's an important movie
to see and i think with this movie it it
it serves all those messages in in a
very accessible form
it's it's a great story you're involved
in you know in this comics world and you
know this uh
all these superheroes and yet um
they're very strong messages and they do
come through
and it's a great forum to
to show it to people
so people are you know it's a surprise
people don't expect it
lots of people are very excited about it
i'm happy and embrace it
um and some you know for those who
were thrown off by the fact that it's a
woman i
i think i think it's um you know
especially nowadays
you know we are fighting for the fact
that everyone is equal and gender
really shouldn't matter and it's not
about what gender you are it's about
what skills you have
[Music]
i cannot be intimidated actually
and there's nothing i can't be talked
into
so you can you can talk to me as much as
you want
there's no if i don't want to do
something there's no way i will agree
to it in the end so the only
so the mental pressure doesn't work with
me
it just doesn't and i'm not that
desperate about success i'd rather let
go
i don't need to succeed if it is if it
means i lose my career i'd rather lose
my career
but i will not do anything
[Music]
like for me to obviously you would need
to physically
you know force forced me and that that's
just all
other level and it's a different and
even then i would fight
[Music]
oh well i see big changes i see people
well
changes are also obviously flips to the
whole other side and it becomes another
extreme
um i've seen men terrified to even speak
to women
as a result of it um but obviously i
guess we have to go through that uh
in order to step stabilize it
yeah i got scared because obviously you
know you read all this
uh you know well back then we didn't
know it was i was one of the first
so
i just thought it was a deadly disease
but in the end
i was fine so i think the fear was
bigger than the reality
who isn't dealing with mental uh
problems nowadays i think we all do
and of course you know i'm not i'm not a
robot i i have feelings and i have uh
you know my um you know i get
you know sad and anxious and and i just
how do i deal i just uh
do you know what i i usually read books
help me i read books
on the subject
not right now i cannot say for later but
uh right now no i don't like that idea
for myself but that's my personal choice
and i don't it's not a judgment
everyone does whatever they want um i
wouldn't
because it's me that's my decision but
if i have to
i probably will later i don't know
terence malik once told me he said just
uh
he said uh follow your instinct he said
because you're yours are great
for me the most terrifying thing
is to to have to depend on someone i
don't know where i get that from
again that has to do with my upbringing
and my past and everyone's different
and maybe it would be easier if i accept
it to depend on someone because
it just would be i could just let go a
bit and breathe but
i i don't know how to do that
failure gives me drive if i fail this is
immediate when i think okay
i have to get it i have to get it now
how do i get it and then i'll work on it
yeah and and and prove to myself that i
don't fail at it anymore but it's it's
just for myself i'm not proving it to
anyone
it's my conversation on my own with
myself and that's what i do
so failure actually is a blessing
actually to summer it up if there are no
failures
for me i would never move forward
[Music]
it was great i always admired scarlett
and i
i was so excited to meet her in person
um and uh and i have always had a
feeling that she was a cool girl
you know it's just the feeling that she
kind of
that's the feeling and and and when i
met her um
i realized it's the truth and we really
got along and chatted and she's just
really cool and do you know what
speaking of strong women she's a strong
woman
it just comes through in conversation in
the way she is and
and and i love meeting a strong woman
again it empowers me more it gives me
uh it motivates me
because these people are inspiration
strong people are inspiration
if you want to be strong or or any other
skill if you want to do something
you'll be surrounding yourself by people
that are better at it or
just like it so that you can learn and
get inspired and that's the way to do it
so
yeah it was great working with her
[Music]